We've almost come to the end of another lesson, and
I want to give you a chance to assess your own
knowledge of non-coding regions of our genome. Now, based on
what you've learned, see if you can figure out this following
scenario. A baby is born that shows severe signs of
lactose intolerance when fed breast milk. Now to determine the cause,
the hospital is interested in the sequence of the lactase
coding region, the promoter region and the enhancer region, specifically at
the minus 13,910 base pairs or letters in front of
transcription start site. They're able to determine that there are
no mutations in the coding region of the gene. So
what I want you to figure out, is select whether you
think a gene mutation is more likely in the promoter
or the enhancer region. Then I want you to justify
your answer here in this text box. Tell me why,
and do this in your own words. Make it a little
short answer essay. Include any word you need to answer the question. Use words
like transcription, allele, consensus, transcription factor, whatever
you think you need to answer the
question of why, when you justify your answer. And keep this answer in a
safe place, because we're going to use it
in the next video screen to evaluate ourselves.